hello friends its Celtic here and I'm
here to give you an update on my channel
just kidding it's actually me mass mint
and a bandit oh I want to let you know
I'm absolutely not sitting alone in my
apartment in my underwear with this
light in my face giving you an update to
my channel I wanted to say hello to you
in a more casual fashion and I hope you
all are having a very spooky Halloween
season so far I just wanted to take a
little bit I just wanted to make a more
casual video that's really just me
talking to you my subscriber base
because the last time I did something
like this was probably around the Oh
4,000 subscriber mark and that was about
15,000 subscribers ago or something like
that so the vast majority of you have
probably never seen my face and never
had me talk directly to you so hello
it's me bandit what I'm going to do
tonight is answer a few questions that
nobody's asking but I'm going to answer
it anyway and give a few updates to
where the channels going in the future
as well as explain why I don't have a
regular Theory video up right now and no
I'm not going to make you look at my
face in this light that much longer in
fact give me just a second I'm gonna go
over here alright
and yes I'm literally just sitting on
the ground right now let me adjust this
a little bit and we can get right back
to it okay so now that I'm being normal
for two seconds of my life
hello once again Mastan bandit here oh
my goodness there's nearly 20,000 of you
now just earlier this year I was
thanking people for 200 200 subscribers
and now we are very very rapidly nearing
the 20,000
to zero zero zero zero did I get that
right yes to zero thousand subscribers
mark and that is just absolutely insane
I can't even wrap my head around how
many people that is I can't even wrap my
head around what it would be like to
look at that many people I mean I'm
pretty sure there are some towns that
have fewer people than 20,000 so that's
absolutely insane to me I just wanted to
say thank you for being here and
stopping by and looking at you know me
and this channel and everything that is
in here and thinking hey I want to stick
around excuse me hey I want to stick
around for some of that so thank you
that means a lot we will be continuing
to go onward and upward from here so
continue to like comment and share get
your friends to subscribe let's see how
big we can get shall we all right now
I'm gonna cover a couple questions that
nobody was asking but I'm gonna cover
him anyway first question
Massimino bana you got such a long name
is it a ripoff of Nintendo black crisis
actually no it is not a ripoff I've been
wanting to come out and tell you guys
about this for a while I came up with
the name mask Nintendo bandit a long
time ago we raised this building anyway
I came up with the name master who
invented a long time ago when I was like
in seventh grade maybe it was this
really really cringey name I came up
with myself and I put it as my facebook
picture I liked poorly edited like a
bandit mask over my face and then I was
like the masked ninja movie anyway a
couple years ago when I was making this
channel or thinking of ideas for a
Nintendo themed gaming channel I was
like you know what there's there's you
know channels out there with quirky
names I mean quirky names are kind of
where it's at
there's peanut butter gamer
Nintendo black crisis there are a whole
bunch of really quirky sounding names
out there so I thought you know what I I
made this name a long time ago and it
might just be quirky enough to work I
was like math Nintendo band-aids I'm
gonna go with me and you know what I
think it's stuck I think I'm pretty used
to being called mash Linda banner oh and
by the way on that note I have such a
long name what's the nickname well some
people call me masks some people call me
masks which i think is a little weird
but I mean it works and some people just
call me Babbage any of those work you
can call me mask II tell me bandit you
can call me Nintendo if you I mean if
you want to call me Nintendo I may not
respond to that but you know you go for
it or if you want to type out an acronym
you can type out M and B that's right M
and B couldn't get easier you see you
see a little keyboard down there if
you're at a computer you see your little
C little keyboard down there go ahead
look at it for me a you see the bottom
row of the keyboard right on top of the
spacebar you see how it says B and M
yeah that's right all you got to do is
just hit those three backwards and you
got my my acronym right there couldn't
be any easier
yours truly mm deep making it easy the
second question that nobody's asking but
I'm gonna answer anyway is uh am I going
to cover non Zelda content and the
answer that is absolutely yes I actually
kind of tested the waters with that a
little bit ago note with covering smash
content we had the Nintendo Direct
earlier this year and it brought with it
the reveal trailer for Terry Bogard
anyway I covered that video a little bit
ago and it got some pretty decent
recognition so yeah I'm absolutely going
to be covering more than just Zelda
stuff I think at first I'm going to main
you know stay within the Nintendo realm
so you know Mario Samus Luigi even our
boy Luigi anyway if you guys want to see
stuff like that give me a comment below
you know let me know kind of what sorts
of things you might want to see here at
the masked Nintendo bandit or M&B for
short yeah the third question that
nobody's really asking me but I feel
like I need to answer anyway because I
am
not have a guilty conscience about it
spoiler alert I do have a guilty
conscience about it is a 10k subscribers
special video where is that what
happened to that that is a very good
question okay so everything that my
channel is essentially just blew up
since mid this year and it's all been so
crazy I personally work full-time at a
hospital in in downtown near a major
city that I'm that I live by that takes
up a lot of my time and so you know I
really I've only just recently been
devoting this much time to this channel
and giving it one video a week treatment
things like that and it's been great you
know I've seen growth there's a lot of
you here now that I've I'm having the
pleasure of meeting and talking to in
fact if you subscribed within the past
three months and you're watching this
video and you're listening to me say
this right now
give me comment below and let me know
what video made you subscribe in fact I
will pin that in a comment below tell me
what video of mine made you subscribe
anyway back to my question what happened
to a 10k subscribers special well you
guys happened by the time that I was
done like editing and finishing whatever
video I was working on when I hit 10k we
were already at like 11 or 12,000 and I
was like well shoot you know I just like
I don't have that much time and I need
to get something out but then I also
needed to meet the quota of like just
regular uploads but anyway before I knew
it we were at 15k and then we were at 17
K and then I was like you know what
whatever I'll just do a 20k special and
then within the past week we've gone up
like several thousand subscribers so
it's really just whizzing by and I'm
basically I'm going to create a special
thank you video just for subscribers in
general like for all of you that are
here now and that'll come out I'm you
don't don't quote me on this but I'm
planning on doing a big special
something around new
so you heard it from me first
now fourthly here's a question that some
people ask quite a bit actually on the
mass mminton a bandit
where's my mask that's a good question
so you see I am but whatever reason when
I named myself the masked man in the
Bandit I didn't really ever think maybe
I should have a mask with the name so I
don't have one but that doesn't mean
that I won't be finding one so stay
tuned and real quick before I end I just
wanted to say that I am
besides my two amazing mods and discord
that I have currently I am really the
only person who works on my stuff here
at masa kinda bad editing music
recording scripting whatever that that's
all done just you know by me so if any
of you out there feel that you could
lend a hand with any step of my video
making process be that you know music or
making an intro maybe or you know
anything if you want to help out with
this channel what I'm saying is please
find my email on my on my channel page
you can go to about and scroll down a
little bit you may have to do a CAPTCHA
or something like that but you should be
able to see my email on my channel about
page shoot me an email um let's let's
set something up if you want to help out
with the channel here anyway guys that's
all I've got for you I just wanted to
take a little bit of time to sit here
and say hi to all the new faces and talk
to the people who have you know been
here who are interested in what's going
on in this channel give a couple updates
and I want to remind you that on
Halloween I'm uploading a pretty good
video so you guys are gonna want to be
here to watch it just remember Halloween
I'm uploading a special until then you
guys have a very spooky October without
further ado this is master - no bandits
signing out
[Music]